hello everybody hope you're having a
great
tuesday i can't believe it's been a week
it's just my
my days all my weeks are really flying
by and it's
really scary whoa that would be the
youtube from my ipad
um okay so hopefully you are
having a interesting chess week
there has been some different events i
played at the
collegiate rapid and blitz event over
the week slu
won the rapids but in the blitz i don't
think we were as successful
i believe webster won it but yeah
that was a that was interesting weekend
i was reviewing anki flashcards middle
of the rounds don't tell alejandra
yeah i think it's been great going great
so far but
all right so um i can see people
are joining all right great hello
so last week i showed some dynamic games
including a game or two
of topolof which i realized wow
topography really has some
awesome games so i dug a little deeper
and i have more topolof games for you so
if you want to
name this title dorsa's fascination with
topalov games
or doors up anything just like anything
just like he he's such a great chess
player
and he's also a very like just
warm person but all right
enough about that so yeah i have one
game that he played against karayaki and
another one that he played against
kramnik i wanted to show
another game that he also had but i
usually don't have enough time to go
over more than two
so we are just gonna focus on these two
and i don't think we're ever gonna run
out of topolof games
so we can just have a whole segment on
that
okay so um also this is
my one of the first times of
using leeches for showing games
so yeah hopefully it will go
smooth if not take it up a tracy
i should go alright okay so
um also for those who are looking around
fish is sleeping in my books so you
probably could see
his head oh yeah as soon as i said his
name his ears moved okay
so you get your dose of cuteness from
there as well
all right um let's start
so ah i don't like that leeches is
showing arrows but
let's just go ahead i also want to
disable the sun i don't want to hear the
moves
all right so sicilian i tried it with
black
i have horrible like some like some of
my most horrifying
games as black when i played sicilian
or carl kahn that was just
that that was a that was just yeah just
thinking about it i think if there was
ever like a
horrifying prize for a game i would
definitely win that
but yeah so
i actually might maybe one day but if am
i doing it for halloween
what's it possibly huh
no 27 well close to halloween i could
pull off like a
horrifying face and put that
sicilian game that i have on oh boy
that should scare everybody but enough
about me let's go back to topalop's game
stop as good games
i'm running out of good games oh this
weekend alright
um so in
this game it was between
cr karjakin and topalov but i don't know
why i thought it was kramnik for a
second
kramnik is the next one top off was
white on that all right so this is
actually
oh yeah this was this was the the very
interesting game so
all right i'm not gonna talk too much
about the opening especially because
these games
well i feel like everybody also kind of
know what they're doing
in the opening if you're playing this
either as why there's black or if you've
never encountered this position then
you're probably a d4 player
and you probably don't play as black
um yeah uh just
okay so to me i've had a lot of
different games in this position from
white
i tried deny dwarf and when when i
played with black and that's
kind of my horrifying experience because
i didn't necessarily know exactly what i
was doing
and as soon as my opponent like switched
some ideas and some moves
i was just like a kid who took their
candy away and i was just completely
lost
um but yeah so if you don't know what
you're doing in the opening
it's not a good idea to go play it
unless you actually have some idea like
i never understood why people keep
telling their students
or like each other like hey we should um
you should expand your opening and like
just go play today go play sicilian
tomorrow go play french
even super grandmasters or just
grandmasters don't do that if they don't
actually know what they're doing in that
position
have the most up-to-dates have the
material but
okay so
yep that is especially cool um i think
there they have other names for it too
but i grew up learning this was
swishnikov so i'm going to stick with
swishnikov
i do play this line and actually if you
guys have watched
other videos of mine you would have
probably seen that i did a video
on how i almost crashed but i got
crushed
by anna muzuchuk in this opening but i
was playing white she was playing black
i was i was having a really great
position and then
bam bam boom yeah
yeah that was hurtful okay
so i actually play the c4 line more
often
um not because it's better but because
it's a little bit more trickier in my
opinion
because well you can let me put this
ipad somewhere so i can actually all
right so you can see that you're trying
to ideally like bring this knight
because this knight here is just weird
um what else you're trying to do
we could try to um
this c4 b4 you'll still do this knight
c2 attacking the pawn you want to bring
this
um the one thing about c4 that if you
if you are considering playing is that
with c force this square gets really
weak
[Music]
and um okay
no i think ah well even um
brutally ironical even if you if even if
you're in the level that you're
both of you guys don't know you you
knowing is better than
you not knowing so i always grew up
really liking
to know what i'm doing like i i want to
know i want to know the opening i want
to know
what am i doing because a lot of the
games that i want come
to be completely honest that's just
basically because i knew what i was
doing and my opponent didn't and i just
wanted the opening didn't even have to
know enough end games
so if you don't like end games that here
is your chance know enough openings so
just kill the opponent the opening and
never get to the end game
that's one way to do it okay so um
anyways in in high level chess they
mainly play c3 rather than c4
there are some sacrifices on b5 that
have been tried not in this position
but so if you are into super tactical
stuff that's another idea that you could
try
but topolof is super dynamic and he
didn't try in this game
so so far everything is going great ah
not supposed to
crack cardio yeah i keep i don't know
why i always
mix up the players who are supposed to
be
um no it's not about being lazy and
avoiding it's more about some
just like some people have a preference
some people prefer
playing with a queen some people prefer
end games there is that
like biasy there is that preference but
it doesn't mean that
you can't play the other like you can't
play with queens or you can't play
without queens it just means
you prefer it so you can use that
preference to your advantage
nothing wrong with that alright so
i want to ask my first question what do
you guys think about this position do
you want to be white do you want to be
black
you do need to know some basic endgame
that is true
you can't just completely avoid them
because you can't
know for sure that you're never gonna
actually get to the end game like that's
just a weird thing to
think you should have like your basic
survival knowledge of end game but you
don't
you don't absolutely in like a lower
level you don't absolutely need to know
every
single theoretical end game
i kind of like i'm not gonna lie this
knight on d5 is really bothering me
from blackside so
[Music]
i'm still like i'm still on the verge do
i want to be white i want to be black
but one thing that black could do in
close future is f5's well not right now
but
probably king h8 soon so
yeah i see that i see that the
the comment about space yes we
definitely
you know care more about the space too
especially in these kind of positions
so in the game one more thing to
consider
is you see this pawn here it's all right
but at the same time i don't want to
have to deal with
potential like attacks on it
so what about rp8 let's just get rid of
this idea that you can try and use this
pen
so i really like this just like kind of
like
you see somebody pinning you and you
don't just sit there and watch it you
move away
i like this yeah um
i do also like um the strategical
advantages
compared to dynamic but to be fully
honest
i've i like i really like dynamic first
and then i really
like learned how to think about a
strategical position
so i can't change my preference but
yeah right now i'm more comfortable
playing strategic
than dynamic as well so maybe that's why
i'm so fascinated with apollo's games
right now
okay so rp8
rook a2 and there are
just uh last movie we're talking about
potentially
trying for f5 so gotta move this king
so the thing is because we have two
bishops we would ideally
want to exchange um
another exchange open up the center
right so if we can open the center
that would be kind of awesome right also
i think
my camera is
yeah i think i'm lagging oh man
[Music]
all right give me a second i think it's
because i have chest space open under
here let me close chess base
my computer seems to really dislike
chess base
for some reason
should be a little better at least it's
not making
ice age noises
i think yeah i think um
all right i think it's better we'll give
it a little bit more time if it's still
lagging then
oh
okay chespa is officially completely
closed
should be all right now right
so yeah we were talking about two
bishops we want to open up the center
right
so in order to be able to open up the
center well d5 is kind of
super disney idea we're never going to
be able to do d5
in this lifetime so how about we try for
like
f5 f5 we want to like take on e4
we want to potentially open up the
stroke i like it we got two bishops we
gotta open them up
otherwise then why are we doing what are
we trying to do
um so
[Music]
oh wait who's sending me pistachios
thank you thank you be easy yes i am a
big pistachio fan having grown up in the
middle east of course i
grew up like just statues
yes um also i kind of really like
saffron ice cream if anybody is
importing i found a great global
global market closed dish so i get my
ice cream supply from there
but okay i can't start thinking about
ice cream now otherwise topalov will go
bye bye and i gotta go get my bucket of
ice cream so let's let's
just think about this position um
so actually after king h8
we want to play f5 so white kind of has
to stop it or at least has to delay it
because
well otherwise uh i mean what would just
be a sitting duck
so um knight e3 seems one way to try and
stop it
or delay it so my question to you guys
after 93
shall we take that knight or should we
still try and push for f5
somehow what do you guys want to do
um sofia i wouldn't worry about it too
much since
a lot of people view it from different
time zones it usually
goes up pretty fast within 24 hours
i actually did this thing that i
probably i don't know
how to feel about it i kind of started
reading the comments i really liked it
so thank you guys for putting so many
comments in the last few videos
it's kind of nice i thought about
answering and i was like hmm
should i should i not i also don't
really have a youtube
youtube like account streaming account
on my own so all right i see
a lot of people just you're pretty
divided but i think
mainly you guys just want to push huh
so yeah i think
we the problem is if we will if we were
to play this f5 right away
then knight f5 take take
um take and this i mean
we should try to figure out which um
what's the safest way to attack because
right now
then white could have some stuff with h4
and then it could bring up the queen
pretty fast
and the knight is already in the ideal
position the bishop is also
limiting our king so we don't really
want to give that option to white
so i think it's not the best choice to
play this f5 right away
um something about something with like
knight e7
i would understand that i think 97 might
be pretty pretty chill
97 um
take take don't worry about a5 because
we're attacking b2
knight d5 maybe queen
too far i'm just like d7 maybe it's
trying to go
some cool places yeah or coin e8 so if
when we play f5 queen comes out of here
yeah i kind of like this
i would um i was thinking maybe knight
e7 but topalov
took took then knight e7
and um here karjakan just went b3
and finally we got this f5
so what do you guys think is it a better
choice for white to take this or to play
knight d5
oh i got a message from tracy she's
gonna put the first comments
so guys make sure to build up on tracy's
comments
yeah oh what is she gonna say
probably something regarding my
inability to
use leeches
i kind of like knight d5
but like also at the same time i feel
like something with
um whoa where's my voice
um knight takes f5 might also be
interesting depending on how you follow
it up
because if as black i get this like
bishop up here
then d5 then ooh black is doing awesome
so i feel like that's something that um
white should look out for but i
i think this is a decent position for
both sides i
don't necessarily like white to be
honest but i'm not saying white is
losing
so just a matter of preference yeah
knight d5 i think it's just a little bit
more
um active zone id5
so question how are we gonna get these
guys out
hi old uncle bob
that's a great username i'm very
not creative when it comes to username
everywhere my
usernames are like dorsa d dorsetd98
when i when i've already used that then
i put another d after it
some people really have awesome
usernames and i'm just like huh
[Music]
yeah i think we got to get that queen to
g5 eventually i wouldn't say
just yet because we also have to be
cautious we don't want to completely
lose up
this pawn and we don't necessarily have
like an attack
attack we're not really forming an
attack because like castle
and even if something like knight h4
still knight e3
stops everything or even f3 stops
everything because you know
just kind of rook here so we don't
really necessarily want to do that
so um how about bishop b7
because our bishop is not really ever
gonna do much
in this diagonal so we might as well put
it in the diagonal that's gonna actually
do something useful
also also we're not necessarily closing
our rook because the
rook is also not doing anything in this
uh file anymore so
i like um bishop
b7 yeah
all right so bishop b7 castle
roxy8 remember i just said our rook is
not doing anything so let's put it
somewhere that's actually doing
a little bit at least so now
queen d3 knight is four is one of those
common moves
um knights are generally good when
they're actually
attacking something or have some taking
away some
critical squares your knight here just
looks fancy but it's not actually doing
anything
your knife is actually putting some
ideas on g2
maybe want to do queen g5 i like this
so um
after knight h4 rook d1
so i did not understand this move in the
game
when i was looking at it so topology if
you end up watching this video
please put a comment on why you played
h6
because i really did not understood it
understand it like
i get a feeling that okay you played h6
just because
um well you also don't want to
necessarily show your hand on exactly
what you want to do
but h6 was out of my scope so
need some explanation on that i i wish i
could provide some explanation but
i would not play h6 in the game um
i don't think i would also do queen g5
either because i don't like queen g3
but something maybe a little bit more
some maybe like rook c5 kind of like
this
stops the defense this you're not going
to really do any v4s
i kind of like this um maybe i want to
do like a knight g6
take something here do like a knight f4
that kind of
feels good i
have never done streaming on my own
not because i'm lazy because i don't
necessarily have the time if i have the
time
i sleep yeah it's last
few years have been pretty rough next
few years will be even harder
if slash when i get into medical school
right now preparing for mcat
oh yeah
okay so um with that comment
h6 i think uh h6
if anybody wants to share their thoughts
on why h6 please feel free to say it now
or later in the comments i will come
back and
read them because i'm procrastinating
and studying
so uh yeah
please i would really appreciate some
insight okay so h6
obviously i'm not going to play queen g5
nor nor is the power of
um knight f5 queen g4 and now
topolof did the move that i suggested
instead of h6
rick's c5 i just feel like rxt5 is just
one of those
moves that's a little weird but not too
weird
because you are attacking the knight
defending the pawn so your queen is free
but at the same time the rook on c5 is
just
kind of awkward because it's not
actually like
achieving any goals when you play like a
rook to sixth or fifth rank you're
usually trying to switch slides
but yeah um rook c5 i think
i'd like to think in a game i would be
able to do it but
kind of make sense to me no objections
there
so yeah h6 undefending the g6
clip square pretty deep yeah that's one
way
um no i think rc5 is generally just a
like a um h65 i think those are
the moves to that the position needs i
want to say
because we don't have a dark squared
bishop we're defending the dark squares
but i feel like that's such a cliche
thing to say so
i'm not officially saying that um
all right let's take a deeper look at
trixie five
okay so we can see that this pawn is
a cool target for opponents at the same
time the knight is defending it
and we this knight doesn't really have
any intention of going anywhere
so yeah um black to move
what should topolof do yeah i don't
have much high hopes of topology
watching this either
you know maybe he's bored to scrolling
through saint louis chess clubs youtube
channel and sees this sure that would be
cool
are you guys gonna start pinging him now
but yeah some of most of the puzzles
that i do or the games that i show
are from deceased players or myself
so that's kind of um like i already know
what i'm thinking and i can't really
ask the deceased people to answer don't
have that ability yet
so that's the problem all right
um queen g5
nope i am not nope i'm not gonna
exchange the queens at least not in the
next
few moves because if we exchange the
queen is then black is left with a
pretty scarred up position
for his pawns let me rephrase that
you are left at somewhat of an
unpleasant strategic
position here we go you kind of lose
your dynamic
how old am i i am 22
and half i guess ugh
i'm my vision i was 18 with my current
knowledge
yeah if i had the power i think that
would be my
when to go back to but i want to keep my
current brain
um so i think so i see this idea like
from something with quincy and something
with drift c8
uh bishop c8 bishop see it is the best
one because
another way to think about it you gotta
make a decision are you going to eat
this
not right now so do this bishop c8 and
the funny thing
is after karayaki played queenie four
tapalok was like
all right well why not let's see if our
opponent wants
to do our petition and that's something
that i've actually talked pretty deeply
about in
other games that have been repetition
and that's a technique that i've used
myself
if you have watched my other videos i've
definitely spoken about this before
you don't necessarily have to want to
make it draw to do the repetition
you can just do it to see what your
opponent says
if your opponent wants to do it huh whoa
don't go anywhere
great if your opponent doesn't want to
do it no problem
so whoa wait why is my no
stop going stop stop leeches
okay bad leeches yeah um
i think that's something to keep in mind
we shouldn't
avoid the idea of repeating moves
because we are trying to not make a draw
we can do it to gain time
when you're in time travel you can do it
to psychologically mess with your
opponent
so it's like you're like offering a draw
but not officially
you also want to see if they do the
third repetition then if the power is in
your hand are you going to accept their
unofficially to stand not not spoken
draw or are you gonna do something else
and most of the time when people do
something else
then the opponent is either like a
little crushed or needs like a minute to
himself to
get his motivation back up so yeah
repetitions are fun um so
ergo bishop b7 and so now
white's uh karjakin did not actually do
the queen g4
anymore um so
it's my understanding that white would
ideally
want to do something with um
you know white has more space so
probably something ideally against this
king
against this pawn so that those should
be the long term plan
but right away white cannot achieve them
so in order to try and achieve them
karjakin played h3
now again karjakit if you watch this
video be sure to leave a comment
to say why you played h3 because
h3 is again one of those moves that i
kind of understand
but i'm just like huh
so yes i feel like h3
um i'm not necessarily recommending
queen g4 and going for the repetition
but at the same time i maybe something
like b4 maybe it's time
but h3 yeah
yeah i kind of i'm i'm in between two
like every move my preference kind of
changes right now with h3
i'm not regretting this bishop b7
because okay
it's true now i get this knight h4 and
with knight
h4 now we are actually doing some ideas
for white's king however in the game
karjakin played
a whooping bishop d3
threatening mate on h7 so question
um black to move how do we stop the mate
what are some of the move preferences
yeah the goal is to play the goal was to
play something with bishop d3
um so i get that white wants to play
this g4
but
g4 also extremely weakens the kink
so um
you basically have two choices either
you're gonna bring the knife or you're
gonna bring the rook
no g6 just gives me creeps
g6 um you're also weakening your h6
pawn so something like queen e3 and um
that's not making me very happy my king
g7
uh bishop v4 defending this now my
bishop is in an awesome position
well white's bishop is an awesome
position this
knight is in a great position no this is
this is
way better for white we shouldn't allow
this
queen move and then bishop
e4 out yeah i made some
changes in my run and now i don't have
enough room for my feet
that's going to be a interesting
challenge to overcome from us
championship don't know where to put my
legs
um oh yeah uh
[Music]
okay so i see there are some ideas with
dirk f5 and knight f5 i agree
one of those two how about drink five
what are you is there anything that
you're absolutely worried about when you
play rook f5
because with rook f5 it's like um
with rook f5 you're bringing your rook
but you're at the same time exposing
your rook to potential discovery attacks
i'm aware of the noise on the microphone
i tried to make it a little better
apparently i failed
and i don't think it's the noise that's
the problem the problem is that the my
laptop overheats and throws in the noise
so that's also another thing that'll be
interesting for us championships huh
yeah i gotta figure some technical stuff
out before
the tournament because the last thing i
want is my laptop just giving up on me
middle of the game i think
that's the worst way to lose i actually
know the worst way to lose is when
opponent castles and gives you
checkmates but after that that's losing
because of your laptop
is the worst way to lose
yeah also great to know that i have some
persian
speakers in the chat it's good to know i
usually get
some um regulars on the twitch channel
but i think i've never seen you around
here bedrooms but welcome
okay so enough psychobabblings let's go
back
to the actual game um
with rook f5 so
is there i i kind of asked this is there
anything that actually worries you guys
and i saw some g-force but i'm not
really worried about g4 because well
first of all
haha make your king weak second of all
this knight is dropping
i can just take over the bishop i can't
take with the rock
yeah i please take that also can i
do i have this maybe knight f trees now
i'm not gonna really
stay on knight f3 when there's a free
thing to eat i'll definitely eat that
so i wouldn't really worry about g4 but
bishop b1
is something that potentially could be
worrisome because now the nikon d5 is
defended
and um so that's one thing
so now what do you think we should do as
black so this
is actually one of the critical moments
in the position
because well for the first time
black is actually has enough room to
breed
and black is trying his best to try and
you know
um eat some ponds or
form some attack you see all of the
pieces are doing
something useful well maybe not the
queen as much
but so can we eat this pond
that is my question can we get to eat
this one and get away with this
yeah not many iranians actually do
stream because of
i assume the internet issues in iran
which i mean if i was in iran i wouldn't
it's way too much problem to stream
so yeah
okay so i see some a lot of no's
actually
wait what is wrong why can't i eat this
if i if i take this i see
that um
i actually haven't seen why but i
haven't really actually gotten a reason
i see a g4
but i don't think g4 is actually
worrisome because now i have knight f3
even if i didn't want to do this request
3 just line up 3 should be enough to win
because
um let's take in g2 i take over here you
take this can i just
take here and then take on b1 yeah
i think this should be enough to win
so g4 doesn't work
you can't really take that because i
will definitely eat your queen
you could take it but i will eat your
queen so
you could think about queen five i guess
but knight f5 and if you
take on c3 i believe the biggest problem
is that knight d4
and my knights are my knight is
centralized now i get the chance to
bring the queen
and your rooks don't really have open
files oh hello josh
oh well yeah probably sacking the queen
does look like it
um not the grandmaster here josh's so
we're gonna go with that but um
i don't yeah i
i don't want to give up my queen if i
could play something maybe with like
rook d3 or
c2 and keep my queen that's what i would
do if i were white
and actually in the game karjakin i keep
saying kramnik
played queen g4 as well
and so after queen g4
let's see um what do you want to do
it's obvious both of your is under
attack so
you should have something smart to do
either otherwise
drew c3 was a mistake so what do you
think is that smart thing to do
so let me rephrase black to move
how do we get away with not losing one
of our rooks
what is wrong with knight e3 um
well your queen your knight is pinned
well that's a great question manish
well we can't really just take this
knight because if we take it and just
takes on f5
and now still attacking this and i i
don't want to do this
i don't want to lose some stuff if i
wanted to lose stuff i wouldn't have
taken trick takes c3
um rook f3s don't necessarily work
knight f3 uh-huh
so let's knight f string he just takes
back with the pawn and your two rooks
are still hmm actually there's rook g5
let's g5 knight takes c3 rook stick g4
[Music]
take back take d1
yeah okay that actually looks pretty
good um
knight f3 hmm
how about knight f3 i just played
something like
checks no i should just take this right
what am i missing yeah that's it
that's that's it white has way too much
material for a queen
so yeah knight f3 doesn't work
rook g5 now also i don't believe it
works
because again take over here
take on g4 take and d6 is falling
and remember the only like the position
that we
saw if there was a
um if like your knight if the knight was
on d4 then okay i like this position i
would play this
but your knight on h4 is also paralyzed
and okay attacking g2 but can be stopped
with a simple f3
your pawn on d6 is super weak the rooks
are
gonna start attacking your king so this
is actually much better for
white in this position so that's like
like plus five
so yeah um the knight f3 wait knight f3
king why would
why would i play kingish one you could
play knight f3
because king is one yeah we take over
here you take over there
i guess i can take this okay yeah this
is much better for black
but i don't see why would uh well no
it gave up the proof why would white not
take it
take it it's free stuff
so because i also gave the move up
h5 is the strongest move so you know
he's attacking our
our rooks we tried attacking his king
with checks
doesn't really work how about you attack
his queen
right um so the thing is after h5
if um if white were
to play something like queen f5
knight f5 and then you take on c3 now we
have knight d4
so this is the position that we want we
want the knight to be in the center
and then we can form our attack on that
pawn
there's no rook takes d6 don't have to
worry about getting backrank mated you
know
those stuff so that's like when f5
doesn't work
and in the king karjakin played queenie
two
which was a bad move and you will tell
me why
but just to get to tell you what was the
best best move was queen a4
which is a little weird to find because
the whole game is happening here why
would i move my queen all the way to the
other side
and actually the other side is a song by
jason derulo
i've been listening too much to his
songs i need to stop but
this is a very good singing voice and
let's get back to chess before i put a
huge
ad i'm a jason derulo's fan
so um after
queen a4 i think
it's just i don't know if i would be
able to find this queen a4
um so ac it's not
all the time that it would win it
depends on the position it depends on
the activity of the rooks
so if you could take on d6 and then do
like a 48 and then you're picking up my
queen and i don't even really have king
h7 because you have a bishop there
then yeah those two rooks are way better
than a queen
so yeah um so
after queen a4 i
think simply something is queen c6
uh bishop c6
keep attacking the queen because your
two rooks are still under attack
and if you take now this is
this is a slightly better way for white
to do this because there is like an open
file so white could try to
put the rooks up there something like
this i mean
i don't know why i am showing repetition
but that's the general idea to try and
exchange the knight so
her can pick up some pawns
all right um
[Music]
let's go back what if white plays queen
a1
whoa where ah here
um queen a1
this king is beginning to really scare
me like i kind of want to just start
bringing pieces queen g5 comes to mind
rookies history comes to mind yeah you
can't leave your king
that much unprotected i think even queen
g5 is sufficient enough to win rick s3
is much better but i
i think queen g5 is a move that anybody
would easily find
yeah this is just this is pretty chill
queen g3 coming up next all right this
is super winning
okay let's go i want to be able to at
least show
this game before i have to
give the wheels of fortune
to dennis
okay so
queen e2
then what do you think we should do as
black
we already talked about how we want to
bring up pieces so where can we bring up
these pieces
sorry i was messing with the cat i don't
know if you
caught that or not okay i think you guys
are doing great yes queen g5 easy pc
yeah queen g5 you just want to do mate
you know mates are fun
but the best way for white to start this
is
f4 i mean i guess bishop e4 is possible
too but official b4 i think i'll just
take
rook h3 no
yeah their requester is the easiest way
to win because it's not like you can eat
this i'll give you checkmates
so f4 still hoping to eat some pieces
you know a
bunch of slippers under attack so what
do you want to do after f4
yeah rook after is actually better than
taking on a stream but
turkish 3 is something that anybody
should be able to see
yeah we got to take the pawn but with
what because if we take intakes f4
then the knight would take c3 the bishop
could take f5 so you gotta do roof takes
f4 exactly
and um in the game actually karjakin did
something pretty
weird like king h1 king h1 was a bad
move
knight takes f4 is actually the best try
even though it's
a pretty desperate try it is the best
one and
now uh black best move knight f3
check now you move the king um
queen takes f4 this looks pretty um
devastating for white but it is actually
the best try
something like this however
i understand why it would be hard to see
this
i see aryan that's a great question that
i
don't know and since he's um
still among us we have a great chance of
asking him so
feel free to start asking karjakin and
let me know what he says
uh but now asides joking uh kenyatran is
supposed to supposedly like a
prophylaxi move but it doesn't
feel so um prophylaxis because
well your position is already very much
under pressure and you are kind of
losing so either
you might as well try to eat some pieces
so for example maybe knight takes c3
because if knight takes c3 then actually
knight f3
and we could just do queen g3 yeah
take take and this is also super winning
so yeah
uh king h1 take take
and finally this rook g3 i think rfg3
was a great
ah isaac rxg3 was a great move but not
the best move so can you guys tell me
what
is the best move
be easy me too i really wish more
beautiful men played chess too
i wish all beautiful people all
beautiful girls boys
i should have a tournament for beautiful
cats
i'm pretty sure my cats would win hold
on actually wesley saw it does have a
pretty
cute cat all right my cat would
definitely
be in the first top tree
i don't know many good good looking
doctors players though
be easy i think you have good intentions
but be careful it's a very slippery
slope and
i don't think yeah i think that's all
i'm going to say
yeah we do need maybe i'll do a full
segment of beautiful cats
only if this is so agrees to do a stream
cats with me all right
um yeah easy not gonna i'm not gonna
argue with that
okay um before we make this into a
beauty pageant
let's go back to what do you think is
the best move so i see a bunch of bishop
d5s
rook g4s um
some rookish trees i see a lot of
different ideas
and um queen h4 seems to be the quickest
way to win
so i think queen s3 uh i think queen h4
you're still going for like the strickes
tree
right and then you want to do like a
rook g4 or a g3
okay this queen is falling that's
besides the point i think um after queen
h4
maybe white could try something like
bishop d3
network d4 and um
then we could continue for
the five eating
and this seems to be going well i mean
okay maybe
i don't assume bishop jeet is the only
move to play but
that was what the engine said and that's
why i'm showing it but i don't
i wouldn't recommend bishop i mean
bishop jet you're just defending queen
f8 but you could also just play king jia
to stop it so
don't feel the pressure to think about
something like bishop g8
but anyways let's go back to the actual
game so
here actually topolov made a small
blunder because they didn't do like the
easiest way to win he played the rook g3
but this is still pretty winning
so in the game karjakin took
will eat the queen and take on h3
and then rook back to g3 i think the
easiest way to want to win is just push
this pawn
and so this is super winning especially
because well you only have one pawn if
you add a bunch of more pawns then okay
white should be doing all right because
a rook and a knight and a bishop
[Music]
not everybody's dream right
so rook g3 um i think
white gotta try and cover up the king so
something with rook f2
i don't understand king g8
well i guess he was just trying to get
away from these kind of checkmates so
okay
g8 well maybe it was queen e7
no all right kj it's not like the end of
the world
so and finally we can start pushing that
pawn we don't really have to worry about
something like that because
there's a queen d8 and
all right okay now you gotta be careful
there's rook c8
so in the game topolov just went
queen g4 and i believe
that should be significant enough so
no more background checkmates and um
what else what else can we think of
it would be awesome if we won this game
like 10 moves ago but this is
still pretty winning so
defend defend
and so keep in mind if we have the
chance to get this
give up this queen for the two rooks we
should definitely do it because
okay i think everybody would comfortably
agree that this pawning game is super
winning
so that's the idea we should want to
push the pawns get some pieces get
some ponds connected uh if he tries to
take this
well that's that's a lovely blender
and um this is super winning i'm just
trying to show you how
white will lose this
um i highly doubt anybody would lose
this as black
as long as you don't blunder your queen
so yeah um yeah ah actually
never mind uh white's right now resigned
i believe mainly because the if e2 is
coming up queen f4 is coming up
and um oh how about queen f2
oh yeah queen f2 is also coming up too i
like this
yeah so i even queen f1 and entering e2
yeah this is way too lost for white to
want to continue and all right so i
am going to um
end the stream pretty soon especially
because i got dennis barros
who got to do the end game class and
yeah
i think tonight was very good um very
energetic
a lot of interesting stuff in the chat
i'm still looking for that
cat cute duel with
soloistle's cat so make sure that any of
these three people
so wesley karjakin yeah to paul if you
see this stream make sure to leave a
comment
for different reasons topology i want to
know why i played h6
karyakin why you played h3 and so wesley
when are we doing the cat
stream all right um we are i am going to
uh i'm teaching the friday classes on
the twitch channel
so make sure to tune in and watch those
and
i can't believe it's already october
almost
24 more hours so have fun make sure to
stick around and watch
dennis bars show you some cool end games